All right. Hello, hello, hello.
We're gonna go right into it today.
We're going to go start talking about
agentic rag and talk about if we can get
to work, how you would might want to go
do it, and exactly what we want to do.
Before we get started,
>> this is
>> Go ahead, do the intro. You're doing the
intro. Go for it.
>> All right. This AI that works. Every
week, Dexter and I get together and we
talk about building real pipelines that
actually work.
If uh if you can think it, you can build
it. That's the whole idea. And my name
is Vivov. I work on BAML, which is a new
programming language.
>> I'm stacks. I work on uh lots of things,
including code layer, which is a new ADE
to get coding agents to solve hard
problems and complex code bases.
>> And I'm super excited to get into it.
This is going to be I have a feeling we
were thinking about this episode before
we got on. And uh I have a feeling
there's going to be some spicy takes and
some back and forth. So my favorite
episodes are when me and Vibv actually
don't fully agree on stuff. So we might
get a little bit of that today, but I'm
going to let him get into the demo. Show
them what we're building and uh looking
forward to it.
>> Okay. So as many of you probably know, a
rag system is not an aentic system like
cloud code or something is not something
you can really build um in let's say
like within 1 hour. So, I did something
else, which is I built this thing um
mostly uh last night just to show you
what it could do. But I want to just
start with the demo and show you exactly
what it is and then based on what it
works, we can then talk about how it
works. So, I'll just make the terminal
the whole thing. Uh can you see? All
right, Dexter.
>> Yeah, it looks good. That's a that's a
good zoom.
>> Okay, then I'll leave it at the zoom
level. Um I'm just going to run this
thing. Uh we're what this thing is I
gave it a directory. I'm in the BAML
directory right now and I'm just going
to ask it what does the form fern folder
do and you'll notice what this agent
does. It actually has the ability to go
ahead and set some stuff. So it's going
to take the user query. I'm using GD5
for now because I don't want to think
about model stuff. So I just used the
best model I could on the market.
>> Did you just did you build a coding
agent?
>> Yeah, I built a coding.
>> Is that what this is?
>> From scratch. Um
>> Okay.
>> It took me a net of about 3 hours. So it
actually went through it did a glob
looked through the firm folder and I was
like cool this worked.
>> Um I'll ask it question using these
docs.
How does how do I use the Gemini models
with BAML? Cool.
>> It should in theory take this agent and
there's my user query. It'll go ahead
and probably glob some stuff. Um make
some other GP. It has a GP tool that it
looked into. It's going to go take the
results. And I don't stream the thinking
tokens yet. I haven't built full
streaming into this yet. That'll
probably take another two or three hours
to get working. Uh file
>> and then what will it do? Let's just
keep seeing what it does.
>> I got a question.
>> Yes.
>> Um where you're snipping that result at
the end where it says 4,300 cars total.
Is that also being snipped for the model
or is that just being
>> trimmed? The model sees the full 4,000
characters.
>> Okay.
>> Um cool. It actually gave me an example
of how to do this. Um, can you check
against the Google Docs if Gemini 2.5
Pro is the latest model or not? Or are
there newer ones?
>> Did you also give it web search?
>> And while this thing runs, like I guess
a really really important part to think
about here is what exactly are we trying
to do with agentic rag? I know there's
quite a few people who probably have an
idea of what agentic rag is. What is
your definition of it, Dexter?
Um, and I think it's probably worth
zooming out a little bit now that we've
kind of seen the demo. Um because I
think for me agentic rag is basically um
to be to be like counterposed with um
traditional rag which is a little bit
more actually aligned with what we might
describe as context engineering which is
you know uh some query comes in I do a
bunch of deterministic code to fetch
data related to that query whether it is
doing a search on an API like linear or
notion or something like that or whether
it's like pulling things out of a vector
database. Like for me like
retrieval augmented generation doesn't
have to use vectors. It doesn't have to
use search. It's just based on what the
user asked or based on some logic that I
know in my business application. We're
going to retrieve data and give it to
the model deterministically every single
time. So when the model gets the user's
question or query or task or whatever it
is, you are always going to be injecting
some set of and it's probably not the
same every time, but it's deterministic
code mostly that defines what goes in
there. And maybe there's searches and
lookups and XG boost and vectors and
things like that, but that's kind of
basic like your code decides the logic.
And so with agentic rag, it's it's kind
of a little bit more open-ended. It's
this just agent calls tools in a loop.
And so it's the agent's job to define
what context gets pulled into the
context window. And sometimes if the
context is bad, it's still in the
context window, but it's the agent's job
to call tools to try to get the enough
information to resolve the user's query.
>> Yeah, I I'll tell you how I think about
it. And probably it's probably slightly
different, but slightly aligned as well.
Um
my theory is
I think agentic rag the whole purpose of
it is it's actually not a definition of
how you implement it. It's actually more
of a definition of what the goal of the
problem is. So when I think about the
world, I think about a rag system as a
much narrower system. And this might be
exactly what you're saying. But when I
think about um in the sense of like a
narrow system, what I mean by that is
you have a you as a developer have an
understanding of the scope of the
problem that the user is asking. And an
agentic rag pipeline is designed to go
solve for a problem where you as a
developer don't have a scope for knowing
what the user is asking. Well, and this
is what we always talk about is the the
kind of spectrum between the kind of
full open-ended yolo just call tools in
a loop versus the specific pipeline. And
so when you write the pipeline, you have
more deterministic code. You have less
like the problem space you can solve is
smaller. But the idea is by by being
deterministic about the things you know
are always going to work in a certain
way, then you can actually solve that
problem better. like the open-ended
agent can do more things, but if you
want accuracy, you actually want to say,
"Well, we're always going to do these
three steps in this order. Why are we
going to prompt the agent to call those
three tools? Just we'll just call those
APIs and inject it every time."
>> Yeah, exactly. So, here's the thing. I I
want to talk through the code that we
built today, but I think one of the most
important things that I really want to
talk about is
I I had a hot take that I built while
building the system. I think
>> you you learned something new by
building.
>> Yeah. Uh well,
If you are deciding whether or not you
should build an agentic rag system or
not, um you should just build one. It's
way easier than you think. I built the
whole thing, like I said, in 3 hours
using cloud code. Um I wrote I wrote
probably around um I think I wrote about
30% of the code by hand and 70% of it is
AI generated. I don't think I could have
done 100% uh by AI generated personally
uh just because of how nuanced and like
some of the decisions were, but like 70%
of the code is actually all UI code.
very little of it is actually agentic
code. Almost all of it is pure UI UI
stuff I have to build. But I think one
of the first things that I realized
while building this is actually that
most people should not build
rag aentic rag systems for their
workflows. If you're building a software
stack, most problems are not so wide
that you need an agentic rag system.
And the reason I felt this was because
it turns out it's it's very similar to
different kinds of problems. But the way
if you have an Excalibur, let's do some
drawing.
>> I'll send it to you on Slack.
>> I'll show you exactly why I came to that
conclusion after building this. And you
might disagree.
I did not use the cloud agent SDK. I
actually specifically whenever I really
want to go learn something, one of the
first things that I try and do is I
really want to learn it from first
principles and I just find personally
for myself writing the code helps me
understand how it works. If I use the
cloud agents SDK, I don't actually
understand how like what a system is
doing. And by actually writing the code,
I now just I can tell you every little
bit of a system design decision that you
might make trade-offs for and like where
the cloud agent SDK might be useful and
where it might not. But honestly, I
don't think I would have won any more
time by using the cloud agent SDK. I
think it would have actually like cost
me probably more time because certain
things would have been harder and other
things would have been easier.
>> Code in a second.
>> Yeah. And I I would love to talk through
also like the implications for like
building the SDK when you are also
working at the lab that creates the
model because it gives you some
interesting other unlocks that we can
dig into and we'll look into some of the
stuff under the hood in cloud code that
that that you can see if you look at the
full tool responses.
>> So I'm going to go share my screen and
show you the whiteboard.
>> Amazing.
>> Uh share screen. Um,
all right. We're going to talk about
this and we're going to talk about
agents and how how I at least learned
about it. Oh, that was not a good ink.
Uh, whatever. We're going to do it. Um,
so I think the first thing that I
learned was actually the fact that what
is it? What is this agentic rag system
that we have? So, there's actually two
parts here that are really interesting.
The first part is we're going to have a
user query come in and then we're going
to have a we're going to have a response
come out like a user is going to send us
a message like what I've said like what
does the Fern folder do or how do I use
a Gemini API at some point I'm going to
get some sort of reply from the user
that is like something friendly for the
user to go do. Now there's a whole bunch
of hoopla that's going to happen in here
as well that I probably want to deal
with at some point. Uh that is probably
some agent stuff but for now as far as
the user is concerned they're going to
send a query. they're going to get a
response and then after that what I'm
going to do is I'm going to I'm
basically just going to build blocks of
this over and over again in sequence and
that is what builds this agentic system
and I think that is the first insight
that I had which was like what is this
stuff a user query comes in a bunch of
stuff has to happen here and the model
is deciding what is going to happen in
here and at some point the respond comes
out and then I go in that is the key
part that made it agentic for me and
then I decided what are all the tools
that I want to give it over here so I
just came over the list of tools.
Um, and come up is a is a bad term. What
I really did is I just took the list of
tools that cloud code has and I built
all of them. Uh, GP, uh, I had GP, I had
Glob, I had ls,
and then I built these in along with
like a bunch of other tools and I'll
show you every single tool I have in
there. And like I said, all the code is
completely open source so you can
actually go read it really easily. And I
built all these tools out and I even
have like an agents tool that actually
allows you to spawn sub agents. I didn't
show that off. I'll show
>> you build sub agents.
>> I built sub agents too. Sorry. I built
the whole
>> of course.
>> I mean subtasker is like actually
conceptually not that complicated. We've
talked about it a lot. It's just new
context window.
>> Most of the time actually came from UI
time, not from anything else.
>> And I just wanted to build this
workflow. And once this thing completed,
I then wanted to get the response from
the user. And then once the response
came in, the user could send another
message. And then I just do this over
and over again. So for for terminology
just because we're kind of talking about
a lot of things. I think you called
these like the internal things in one of
these blocks is you have like n
iterations. You name calling them
iterations through the tools.
>> Yes.
>> And then I would call one of these like
a turn.
>> Sure. Yeah. We let's we can call that. I
think that's a good that's a good
nomenclature. Uh it's going to make it a
lot easier. I I did come up with a name
for the internal thing cuz I was like
getting confused.
>> What did you call it? I just called it
iterations uh because I needed a word
and that was the word that existed and
I'll post some screenshots just so you
guys have an idea of what that means.
This is Google Chrome is hiding my so
when I go over here this is kind of what
it looks like. I do the same thing. So
like an iteration over here is an
iteration I call a tool and it's
basically a tool transaction list that
runs forever until it basically decides
the only tool that I choose to terminate
on is a tool that replies to a user.
Now, because this can go off spinning
into a loop forever, I actually have to
do some work to just set max iterations
as well. So, like at some max iteration
loop, I just stop it. Uh because I don't
want it to spin forever um and just burn
money. Uh but in theory, I didn't have
to do that. Uh I just needed that. Uh
but now that this worked, what was the
hard part about this? Like why do I
think that most people should not build
this system? Well, it turned out that
the number one problem with this system,
I wonder if anyone can guess. Dexter,
what's your guess about what you think
the hardest part about this whole system
is?
>> Designing the tool prompts and the tool
responses to be usable by the model and
context efficient for the model.
>> Um, tool prompts was actually the I
actually never touched the tool prompts
after the first time of writing them.
>> Did you just steal the cloud ones or did
you write them yourself?
>> I you asked
>> Claude wrote them.
>> I just asked cursor to write it.
Actually, oh, sorry. I said Claude. I
actually used cursor this whole time. I
just wanted to try new age agent. I
actually used cursor the whole time. It
was 70% cursor, 30% me.
>> Um,
>> how was how was the cursor agent?
>> I told you I built the whole thing. If
you think this agent is cool, I built
the whole thing up there.
>> Okay.
>> Um,
so I did that. Um, I also did a couple
more things while I did this. Um, what
what I found was the hardest, sorry,
I'll talk about that in a second. What I
found the hardest part about here wasn't
actually the tool definitions. It was
actually the implementation of the
tools. And when I noticed agent quality,
what's surprising is when I tried this
thing uh with even the best models, the
key difference to making this work was
actually how I changed how the tools
were implemented. Everything else made
zero impact or negligible impact on the
quality of the agent based on the kinds
of tasks that I was doing and the way
>> that's the that's the promise of agents.
That was the promise of agents a year
ago, right? which is like use use a
framework, use the loop and then just
bring your own tools and you control
kind of your own destiny by just like as
long as you build good tools and you
implement them well the agent can do
anything
>> kind of but effectively what I found was
if I need if I define my tools well then
it did work but the other problem that I
did have to do was I did need to have my
tool def my prompt was semi- tied to my
tools and that part was very tricky to
go do right
>> yeah I've seen that a lot I've seen a
lot of people building coding agents
They have it in the system message and
in the tool definitions and then
sometimes even injected to the end of
the user message as well.
>> Conniey's got a very interesting comment
about like testing and evals. Um yes,
while I was building this whole thing, I
was actually constantly testing. So my
iteration loop for running this was
actually one of the first things I did
as I actually built a really really good
CLI tool that was pretty good. And as
soon as I built a CLI tool, I actually
built a TUI because the CLI tool quickly
became unusable
because of how printing stuff came out
to be. And I needed something to
actually
uh I actually needed something to make
my problem be a lot easier to
understand. So, for example, when I get
the GP tool, when I had a giant log
system here, I needed to see the
difference between one tool versus the
next tool very clearly and I needed to
not override my 2E when I was actually
like writing stuff and typing stuff out
into the terminal and that was really
hard to do with just a pure CLI. So, I
found it to be very useful to actually
just build a TUI and just tell the model
to do that. And once I did that, funnily
enough, cursor actually built the right
abstraction layer for my agent as well,
which was it was an agent that ran that
had hooks for every interaction that
happened. Then I could just like observe
it with different states. And that's the
exact UI I wanted. So the CLI and the
TUI both interface the same thing. And I
could have built a web UI that
interfaces the same thing because it's
all
>> so it just emits events and then there's
an out like the interface to it is you
just render the events as they happen
>> basically. Yes.
>> Okay.
>> Uh along the way. So
UI UI loop was really hard designing it.
And then once I designed the UIUI loop
for actually iterating on the tools and
then I could actually go ahead and try a
bunch of prompts. So I actually tried
the Fern thing over and over again until
I finally made it work. And the first
version of this system did not work. The
second version of um the second version
of the system
also didn't work. And eventually I just
annealed it closer and closer to finally
make it work. And I think what I really
want to share today is one the coding
architecture of how I had to go do this.
So let's talk about the tool
definitions. The second thing I want to
talk about is what I did to actually
make the tools better. And the third
thing I want to talk about
>> is what I would do to make this even
better going forward.
>> Cool. So I I I would love to hear more
about kind of what you had in the tools
before you changed them and what you
learned about like what works well and
what didn't.
>> I will I will gladly do that. So let's
get into this. Uh, Dexter, I won't be
watching the chat at all. Uh, so if you
see stuff on the chat, that is worth it.
I'll let you track it. And I'm just
going to walk straight through um
straight through the code.
Um, I'm going to share my whole screen.
Again, if you guys see something I'm not
supposed to, please flag in the chat so
we can cut it out of the stream um
eventually.
>> Careful. We're now live on on Twitter.
So, uh,
>> shoot, this is forever. Um, let's start
with the code architecture now that this
thing works. Uh, I can show sub agents
if you want, but I'll do that at the end
because I think that's the least
interesting part about this. So, I'm
just going to start with the tool
definitions because I think that's the
best entry point to the system. So, I
have two systems that I built. I built
an agent loop that just takes a state.
It has a giant prompt in here. I don't I
don't even think this prompt makes a
difference. I just wrote a cursor wrote
and I just like, okay, leave it as as it
is. Uh, and I just dump out the state
into the prompt and I let it run. And
then I have a separate function for sub
aent loop. And the main reason I have
this is because uh and I don't like this
about BAML. I had to go fix this u once
I discovered this is I have a bunch of
tool definitions. But one second before
I show the tool definition, remember all
this agent can do is it can either reply
with one of the tools or a response to a
user to render something. That's it.
Nothing else is allowed to happen. Same
with this agent. It can either pick one
of the sub aent tools or reply to a
user. Now what are the tools that I
allow? An agent tools are basically the
sub aent tools plus the agent tool.
That's it. That's so the agent tool is
actually call a new agent basically.
>> Exactly. It spawns a new agent. I can go
read this if you want. This is what it
does. Launch a new agent that has access
to any of this stuff.
>> And there's a bunch.
>> This looks like the claw code prompt.
>> I literally just copied the and pasted
most of it.
>> Okay.
>> And then what I did, it's just a
description plus a prompt like nothing
special. It just kind of plumped it
through. Then the sub aent tools are
basically I have a batch tool, a glob
tool, grab tool, less tool, exit plan
mode, read tool, write, web fetch,
to-do, to-do, write, and web search. Web
fetch and web uh search are slightly
different. This uses search API. This
uses actually only the like a fetch to
get a specific URL along the way.
>> Can you can you zoom in a little bit?
>> Yes, I can.
>> Yep. And then the other question from
John was, is it on is the code on GitHub
yet? I think we're going to push it
after this. So, we'll send out an email
after the episode with all the code.
Exactly. So I just want to look at some
of these tools and I this what I want to
talk about is like I actually never
changed these definitions at all. Once I
wrote them it just works. Um and the
only key part to every tool is every
tool has a field called action called
glob action with the name of the action
itself and then the actual pattern that
it rendered. uh and then all the
parameters that came with it and some
and that why I use the action key is
because it makes it a really cool
discriminator for any sort of stuff I do
afterwards to make sure what is actually
happening.
Now this was the easy part. Writing the
actual system was actually quite easy
and once I actually wrote this I think I
have a test case somewhere here. I might
not uh
one second
restart.
There we go. Okay. Once I actually wrote
this, I actually read the prompt and I
think it's worth reading the prompt a
little bit. Uh the model can basically
answer one of these. Uh it just lists
this down and says, "Okay, one of the
actions is bash, tells describes that
one." It then lists the glob action and
then lists all of these. Um funny
enough, I actually only read this prompt
at certain points, which was when a tool
failed. So I actually started off not
reading the prompts at all. Uh and then
I just let it vibe. And the reason I did
that is because I know Cloud Code works.
I know a lot of these tools are probably
based off of cloud code directly. So I
kind of had a good intuition that this
was going to work up front.
Um what I did do however that I think
was not ob what I did do pretty much on
within the first iteration is I I listed
some scary tools. Edit tool, multi-edit
tool, write tool, uh notebook edit tool.
I just didn't want it to write to the
file system. So I just plum these out. I
just
>> I love using scary tools. I was I've
been using the word scary tools since
since we did all this human layer stuff
for human in the loop. What are the
things you want to get approval on?
Right.
>> And really bash tool should also be in
scary tool, but bash is too useful. So I
kind of left it.
>> Scary but not as not as uh as uh plus
EV, I guess.
>> Yeah, I really just didn't want to
change the file system because this was
a reader agent mostly. It's like
supposed to answer questions about docs.
>> One one question in the chat that I
think we should make sure we get to is
like um how did you eval these tools?
How did you score? How did you know that
new definitions were better than old
ones? Was it just vibes or do you have a
testing harness?
>> I just kept on running the tool over and
over again and rather than doing
anything else. And the reason I did that
is because like when I'm in the flow
when I'm in like flow state and I'm
trying to just make it something that
works
running an eval system and like like
okay, I'll show you guys what what the
actual chat log looks like so you guys
can get an idea.
>> I mean, you did you did make an eval. It
was just you uh you picked a a test case
and you ran the same case over and over
again live test case looks like for this
eval right like at at iteration loop
number at iteration loop number seven I
just have a giant message array that I
have to deal with and like how do I eval
this thing in a way that's reasonable I
can't I can't actually go read it. So I
started doing instead is I would just
run the loop and I just look at what
sequence of tools were called in what
order and once I knew what sequence of
tools the parameters I would look at
sometimes cuz the parameters rarely
mattered. I just need to look at the
sequence of tools and there's different
ways I could have done that. I could
have looked at it here. I could have
looked at it in the terminal UI. It
really doesn't
>> what's the chronology here is the the
read is the last one is at the top
right.
>> The top one is the most recent time
stamp right here.
>> What's this red? Why is it red? What
does that mean?
>> So I'll talk about this stuff. It turns
out models don't always follow tool
calling uh in a lot of scenarios. So
I'll talk about hacks that I had to do
to make it actually work like super
reliably.
>> Did it like output a tool that wasn't
valid or like blew up the parser or
something?
>> Yeah, exactly. It would just make up
tools sometimes. And even if it didn't
make up tools, sometimes it would reply
to a user with some interesting code.
>> So
>> that's uh I read that in the crew AI
prompt a long time ago was like do not
hallucinate tools. Do not make up any
tools. They even built a feed feedback
system in to like if the tool was
unknown, it would feed that error back
into the model and be like you picked a
tool that doesn't exist, try again.
>> Yeah. So that that is not that is kind
of pointless. So I didn't do that, but I
did do something else that I think made
it a lot better. So what do I do? I
basically have a run loop system where
you take in a user message and as a user
message comes in you just basically run
the iteration loop and then you just go
exit out and then you wait for another
user message
and once a new user message comes in
then you just keep on going again. So
basically as soon as the user gives you
a new message you just run this loop
over and over again. Why do I have two
loops here? Well one I just want to run
an n number of iterations. So you can
think of this as a turn. Dexter calls it
a turn. I
>> call this the the inner loop versus the
outer loop is what we'll talk about when
we talk about 12 factor agents
>> and I called iteration like this was
kind of how I thought about it and then
the all the iterations themselves ran
inside of this and what each iteration
did was something really simple um it
basically took the iteration it called
the agent loop function that I had over
here uh which is defined over here which
is the agent tools which had all the sub
aent tools and the agent tool described
into it um and then I got the response
and ignore all this stuff. Ignore the
retry logic over here. I'll talk about
that in a second. But once the response
came in, I basically just checked if
it's a reply to the user, I basically
just called the call back for reply to a
user which was rendered on the screen.
And then I exit out of the loop and then
I kept on going. So that iteration has
ended at that point. Uh this iteration
also told me a couple more things. It
was telling me whether or not I should
exit the exit this um whether or not I
should exit the iteration. So what this
thing returns is it returns is complete.
If it tells me I am ready then I return
the result to the outer loop. Otherwise
I just keep going in this loop. And
that's how I manage the system cuz this
system had was a single iteration.
Now once the once the instance came
through I basically checked the um I
didn't need to do this response adder.
It's guaranteed to have it. But I I
guess Claude the cursor wrote that code.
Once it actually wrote this, I did some
hook stuff over here.
>> I checked for interruptions because I
wanted to be able to interrupt it with
control X and other stuff along the way.
So, I was only able to check for
interruptions. Basically, if an action
tool came in, if other tools came in, I
didn't. I checked right beforehand. And
then again, uh cuz it's like
multi-threading, I guess.
I sent a hook to the front end to say I
have a tool call that I'm making. And
then I actually go ahead
and uh where'd it go? Then I go ahead
and execute the tool. Now this was again
most of it. So there's very important
thing. If the tool was a sub aent then
the sub aent we know spawns another
loop. So it would just it actually had
to be handled slightly differently and
it just wrote the re it rewrote the loop
in here with some duplicate code which I
really didn't like but that's okay. It
did the work and then it does it. And
remember sub agent can't spawn other sub
aents. Um so I didn't have to worry
about it calling this over and over
again. It was kind of guaranteed to be
safe. It could originally call sub
agents and that was one of the key
things that I had to stop it from doing.
>> Question.
>> Go ahead.
>> How much of the outer loop passes along
context and history or does it start
fresh on every iteration?
>> Every sub agent starts fresh
>> but uh the outer loop in general.
>> The outer loop preserves the history.
>> Cool. Because you have that array of
messages and so you're just keeping all
of the message objects. So like if I
send another message object here uh if I
actually show what okay if I actually
I'll refresh this page again. If I
actually show my messages object here so
you can get an idea like every single
time I ran this it actually just kept on
building into it or it just built more
and more into it. And you can actually
just read the full prompt and I'll go to
the bottom so you can see these get
really long. It just like when I did
extract the latest announcements from
Gemini, it actually like go did this and
it would just like render this for me
and let me know if it was going on if
that makes
>> sense. So I just stacked everything. I
didn't I did not clear the context
window at all.
>> So two more questions. What is this eval
tool you're using?
>> Um this is a thing for boundary studio
but I'll talk about that later.
>> Uh this wasn't really uh we'll talk
about this separately.
>> Uh what I really want to talk about is
how the agent works. So how does the
agent actually work?
>> Keep going. So, we have the sub agent.
We're able to execute tools. Let's look
at some of these tools. So, what's cool
about this is I actually just did this
and I just said tool.action. I rendered
this. What's really nice is you guys
remember how my certain tools were scary
tools and they're not included in here.
I can actually see that because it knows
that even though these tools exist,
it'll actually never get called cuz
action is not allowed to be any of those
types. So, you get really nice type
safety of knowing what tools you're
using. But now that we're doing this,
what is actually happening? Let's look
at one of these tools.
I think LS is a good No, not LS.
LS is not a good
>> I'd like to see like Glob or Grap or
something.
>> Let's look at Glob. Glob is actually I
think a good example. No, Glob is also
not a good example. I Glob actually I
didn't have to do much with to make it
work. I just did the GP was the one that
I had to do. GP was actually really
challenging to get right. And there's a
couple things. The first thing is the
first bug I had is I wasn't actually
passing the working directory into the
system. So I had to manage state for the
working directory. That was very
annoying. Um, once I got that working,
it was much better. This is also why
cloud code has a CD tool. It's because
when it does the CD tool, it's able to m
it's able to change its own working
directory and its own state
representation
as it's running. And when it's doing
that, what it can do now is it can
actually have it can pass in better
context into the model. If you just call
CD via GP or via bash tool, the model
can't detect that. So what I would do if
I were running the bash tool is I would
at the end of the bash tools execution
loop I would actually grab the current
directory and pass that in. So the
current directory is always relatively
correct for the agent agent.
>> Sorry I want to I want to double down. I
know we have a lot to cover but um
you're saying that if cla in if the
model while running commands includes a
change directory you want to preserve
that directory and leave the agent in
that directory going forward.
>> Exactly. I think that's trash. I hate
that. I actually there's a there's a
flag and claude code where you can
disable that behavior where like when it
runs bash and changes directories
afterwards it will always put the agent
back in the directory it was in. And I
find I get so many better results that
way. And I can I can tell you why if you
want, but I know we have a lot more to
go through. I'll tell you actually we
should talk about this. I'll tell you
why I found it to be better for my agent
specifically because my agent preserves
the entire call stack. the model thinks
it's in that directory.
>> Yeah. But also, can we go back to the
whiteboard?
>> Yes, we can.
>> Um, so here's the here's the problem I
always hit with that is um Claude's
let's say Claude's trying to run the
test, right? And so you go and it runs
this command like, you know, cd uh hld
and go test dot dot dot, right?
>> And then it gets the results back. uh it
makes some changes
and then it tries to run that again and
it so it's it's fshot prompted itself
that the way to run the test is do this
cd and go test dot dot dot but the
problem is is that if you keep the
directory this then fails and so you get
an error and then it has to like think
about like oh I'm actually
>> and like reason about what directory
it's in and then it has to run go test
again or it needs to like cd do
>> I I do my comp which I actually tell it
that the directory change.
>> Ah okay.
>> So see so it makes a s
>> tell it the current working directory in
the prompt so that it knows where it is
and it can think of things.
>> Exactly. Okay.
>> Like if you actually go what do you go
if you go read the prompt that I sent to
the model.
>> Yeah
>> I do that and I give it the full path. I
don't give relative path actually.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> I tried relative paths and that actually
did not work. I had to go to full paths
>> at the end.
>> How did you decide to put this at the
top? did you try putting this anywhere
else or were you always just your
instinct was to have
>> queries that I was running over and over
again to go test it and like it just
worked. So I was like okay good enough
and remember I'm using the openi
responses with the GBD5 thing. So like
it's possible that if I was using a
shittier model like sonnet or like uh
GPD4 or something it wouldn't work as
well but like this worked pretty well. I
know openi specifically really heavily
indexes on trusting the system directory
system uh stuff. What I would probably
also do if I were doing this again is
whenever the directory changed uh if I
ran the batch to I actually built the
thing that detected that in batch tool I
would actually put a additional message
as a part of the prompt that actually
solved for that. So like what I would do
is like whenever I did CD as soon as a
tool happened I would actually just plum
in it's like the directory changed and
put that into there personally because I
think that would make life a lot easier
for the model.
>> Okay. Um cool. Okay. Okay, so you were
in the middle of explaining the GP tool
and how it pulls a directory through.
>> So firstly, I know there are a couple
questions there. I did use RG. You
should use rip grap. If you're building
a grap tool and you don't use rip grap,
uh, incorrect. Just use rip grap. Uh,
rust is great for developer tools. Rip
is rust grap built in Rust and just way
better ergonomically.
>> Yeah. And it used to be so the original
fun trivia the original RG was based on
a tool called AG which is called the
silver searcher which was like written
in pearl and did all this parallelism
through like threads. Uh but it was yeah
it was time to rewrite it in rust.
>> So firstly every single GP tool every
single tool I have is that it will
always return a string. That's what I
did over here. I wish I didn't have to
but I did. The last thing I did was
every single time I ran any subprocess
every single one of them has a timeout
built in guaranteed. I had to do that.
I did a couple more things in here. I
actually had to limit how many files
were allowed to be returned. It just was
going to be too bad in a lot of
scenarios because sometimes like uh the
other reason that I have scary tools is
I saw the model look at my root
directory and I was like hell no, I'm
not going to let it look at slash and
that also had problems with glob and
other tools that I was trying to run. So
I had to go simplify that. So the first
thing was limit directory searches.
Now, once I did that, I realized that
there was another problem that ended up
happening, which was when I did the read
tool.
Many of you probably know Cloud Code
doesn't read every single line of code.
It can't in every file. It's because
it's too complex. So, I had to go build
the same thing out. So, I actually built
a limiter on how reading worked. And I
originally when I didn't do that, it
actually had a much smaller limit of
like 2,000 characters or something that
was just too small. So, I increased the
limit to 20,000 characters, but also
5,000 lines. So either one of those two,
whichever one is fine.
>> But that's 20k per line, right?
>> No, no, no. It's total.
>> It says line characters. Line truncated
at 20,000 characters.
>> That's a bug. I should fix this.
>> Um,
>> it should have been 20.
>> Really, it should be by tokens, right?
But you're not going to bring a
tokenizer.
>> I'm not bring tokenizer. It's not worth
it. But the other thing I had to do when
this actually worked is I actually had
to go write this code to say when with
the truncation notice. Originally, I
wrote just truncated.
But now what I actually had to do was
actually say that oh instead of
truncation this I actually wanted to
have the output the output is truncated
starting at this line to this line and I
gave it information about where the line
was
>> so that it can go through if it really
wants to. Right.
>> Exactly. And then I actually told it to
use a read tool with this parameter. So
I was very very specific in how to go
deal with this along the way. And once I
did this this was actually the crux to
making this work the whole time because
a lot of stuff was actually a lot of
stuff is actually designed to be
truncated. So, for example, web search
and fetch was also truncated. This one
doesn't work as well because I didn't do
that. I had another one where I did
this. Uh, what? No, that's different.
This is the UI stuff. I had another
truncation somewhere. I have to go find
it.
>> Um,
>> so AOS is asking, um, this is great
explanation, but I don't see the rag
related context here. Am I missing
something? Do you want to talk about how
this like maps on to retrieval and
search?
>> Yes, let me go do that really fast. So
what this probably just goes down to
definitions of exactly what is rag. So
rag is a system that takes in a user
query and looks into some database of
some kind that says hey given this
database let me go get a subset of the
database that is relevant here.
I can't delete that dot. So it's going
to go ahead and get like a subset of the
database from this system that matches
the query in some form factor. The
typical way of doing rag is you use a
vector search and you basically look at
all this and you say hey given the
vector search which ones are the ones
that have the highest score and then I
will just go get those and now you have
a rag system that takes a query look
through a database gets you the top
scoring element. Yeah, I think it's it's
really like the difference between like
traditional rag and agentic rag is again
like are you letting the agent call
tools to search for stuff whether it's
GP or glob or vectors or whatever or web
search or whatever it is or are you
basically doing that ahead of time and
just almost like not quite
deterministically but kind of more
deterministically injecting stuff into
the context window regardless of what
tools the agent calls.
>> Exactly. So what I do over here is 100%
of the time when the user query comes in
I call a vector database and like what
is an example of this well like this
system is agentic rag right over here
give it a second so I'll search like how
do I use gemini this thing every single
time queries the database finds all the
relevant pages to this and I hopefully
this will work finds all the relevant
pages to this and like right over here
and then produces a response and this is
great I think for a doc search this is
not bad But what this system is able
what this system is able to do when we
don't 100% of the calling call a vector
database is I decide
if I need to rag anything at all like
for example in order for this system to
actually decide what let's say I sent
this query is that is 1.5 pro the latest
model what this will do in this scenario
is this is still going to actually make
the vector database call and go do this
and it just looks only at my at our blog
post and our docs to go do this because
it's hardcoded to 100% of the time pull
out context in that form factor.
>> Okay. So there's no tool call there.
You're just when you ask when you ask
the question you will always do a search
and always hand that to the agent based
on you know vector similarity to the
user.
>> Exactly. What I do over here is I just
decide if the the model is deciding if
it needs to rag anything at all. And I'm
basically letting it decide exactly
which of the few things I may want to
rag. So for example, one of the things I
could give it is I could give it access
to the same vector database that that
Bammy chat has in our docs. I can also
build what I did today, which is I built
a I basically gave it access to our
entire source code and I said, "Hey, you
can just use this source code however
you want." like search through or do
anything else you want on it. And what
that does for it is it basically treats
it like a rag problem. Um,
>> and you can still do all the rag stuff
in your tool calls. You can do the
reranking, you can do the embeddings,
you can do the search. It's just the
agent is saying, "Okay, I'm going to
search for this." It's going to look at
what it got back and then the model can
decide, do we need to do another search
or do we have all the information? And
that's all kind of encapsulated
generically in the agentic loop. Right.
>> Exactly. It's basically the key part is
like how the decision is being made.
Usually in some code you have some you
have some system making the decision and
here you're just letting the model make
the decision completely and this covered
a lot of different trade-offs. One of
the trade-offs is this question the
ability to ask if 1.5 Pro is the latest
model. That was just something we can't
do in this in the current system as it
is today. We can do it in this system
where I asked the model like is Gemini
the is this the latest model? And what
it did is actually just did a web
search, looked into Google Docs,
actually got the change I guess got the
change logs from the Gemini API.
Additionally, got another change log
from the models page and also uh I think
it did a web where did it go and it also
did a web search for like just where do
I go look for the Gemini API on this
page and that's how it found those
links. It got it and then it was
actually able to tell me way more
information than my docs could ever have
because I'm not indexing and like
updating the vector database every
second of the entire internet.
which is it saying that it is the latest
GA model but there are nonGA models that
are available and there's pros and cons
to both approach
but that's the key difference does that
answer the question well
>> I think that was a great I think Akos
said it was answered well that was a
great question Akos glad we spent time
on that um we have a little bit of time
left um I want to make sure um we can
talk a tiny bit about like RL and owning
both the model and the tool chain and I
also would think it would be really
interesting on this search topic to look
at how you implemented the web search
even if it's even if it's simple because
I imagine you're doing some stuff of
like hey let's take all the HTML and
then use a model to make it more context
efficient things like that
>> that is actually I did none of that
stuff
>> amazing
>> enough like I said this took me a total
of three hours to build the whole thing
so most of the stuff I did was I
implemented to-do tools I implemented
most of these tools every single one of
these tools is basically just baked by
generated by cloud code I did modify
some of them. I'd like to show you the
ones I modified. So, I modified the read
tool.
I did modify the execute batch tool. For
some reason, it didn't have the timeout
in here. I don't know why. It just
didn't. So, that was important to go add
in. The error messages were really
important. Having custom error messages.
Cloud code did that pretty naturally cuz
I prompt not cloud code. Cursor did that
pretty naturally because I prompted it
that I wanted good error messages that
were human readable every single time.
Um,
Glob I had to go change like I said with
the limit to the matches. That was
important. Otherwise, it just added
everything. GP. I showed you how I
changed Grep. Uh, Grep. Did I show you
how to change GP? The big change that I
made to GP was whenever GP was resulting
in itself, uh, one of the things that it
did was it actually outputed the full
path to the directory. I actually
changed GP to always show you relative
path
>> and that was really important for
accuracy. It actually worked way better
once I did that. Before that, it just
>> that's context engineering, dude. That's
context engineering. How do you make it
more context efficient? How do you give
model just the information it needs?
>> Love it. I really wish there was an
easier way to model this, but there
wasn't and it was really annoying. But I
really wish that whenever I rendered
this in the prompt, it would actually
render as just the relative path.
>> But that's that's context engineering.
It's like go under the hood, do the
janky weird thing, whatever it takes to
get the right tokens into the model and
every single token counts. When you're
especially as your contacts get long,
when you save 20 tokens per call and
you're going to GP 30 times, that makes
a huge difference in your outcome.
>> It was really, really different. It was
really, really big. This was one this
was like one of the first failure cases
I ran into. This is also why I started
passing the working directory because I
realized that the reason I need to pass
this in was actually to produce relative
paths and then that also made me uh want
to go update the path as it was running.
This is the other reason by the way
Dexter that you really want to do where
you want the agent loop to have access
to the working directory because you
kind of need to know what directory
you're in to go do this
>> to set up the relative paths and things
like that.
>> To go relative paths. Yes,
>> there was a good comment as well, and I
know we're not going to have time to
talk about it, but having the directory
at the start of your prompt basically
wrecks the entire cache probably, but
that's like an optimization we can do
later, right?
>> I I wasn't trying to optimize for that
in that way. I could have left it as is
and I could have just injected new tools
saying like directory change, directory
change, directory change and not have
modified that if I wanted, but I do know
OpenAI really favors that. So, I would
if that was
>> they favor the first the first beginning
of the system prompt more so than like
down problem. I would actually just move
it out of the system prompt and put it
into a user message saying this is my
current directory artificially and then
inject that in. That's how I would
modify that if I had to.
I definitely wouldn't leave it as a
system prompt and then not modify it.
>> Execute ls, ls had similar things uh
that I had to do where instead of
outputting everything when I ls it, I
actually like tell ls tools exactly if
it's a directory or a file when it
actually ls. So, like if I go up here
and you go look at this. Um
>> Mhm.
>> what you'll see what I mean. This is
another big difference that came out of
this. I hate that I use a thinking
model. Do you see how I actually run
this out? Makes a huge difference in how
you actually read this. It just makes it
easier for the model.
>> And it looks noisy for a human, but it's
actually that's always going to be just
one token. Dur and file are each
probably almost certainly going to be
one token.
>> Yeah, probably. So, it's just not worth
it. It's just way better for me to do
this and not. So that was one thing I
had to do with the ls tool. The read
tool I compressed using the line
truncation thing with instructions of
how to deal with shorter lines, how to
deal with longer lines. Uh execute edit
uh edit tool. I didn't look at I just
removed it.
>> So your edits, did you do old string,
new string, just like string replace
basically?
>> That's clock code.
>> Okay.
>> Um Jupyter notebooks, they actually have
to be dealt with differently compared to
most systems. So the model
>> which is easier to interact with the
cells instead of like editing the raw
JSON. Right.
>> Exactly. So that's why cloud code builds
like a Jupyter notebook editor in that
way. Uh web fetch I didn't really
modify. This is exactly the same. I just
use BS4. Uh
>> when you say you didn't modify it like
what do you mean? Like you mean it's
just once it was generated I didn't
touch like once cursor wrote the
function I just didn't touch it.
>> So how are you okay? So soup.get text is
just stripping out all the HTML and just
giving you the raw text content. Yeah,
that's it. That's all I do in fetch and
I just give a really long give it
truncated and there's no way to get more
truncated. So
>> I know that uh when you use cloud code
it will take the some maybe it's ripping
the text out but I think it just take it
might even just be all the HTML and it
passes it to haiku and it's like here
was the question that the parent model
asked. Can you strip this down and
summarize it as markdown? This is
interesting.
You could add a BML call or something
and this is like deterministic LMS
inside your non-deterministic agentic
rag pipeline the same way you could have
a reranker pipeline or something like
that inside a tool.
>> I could do that here to do call haiku to
summarize the content given the query
>> um and how it's related. I could do that
and I could pass in the summary. The
other thing I could do is I could say
truncated. If you need more information,
use bash to fetch the content.
>> Just tell to use curl to a file or
something.
>> Oh, wait. Not to store.
>> Then you don't get the HTML stripping,
but it's probably
>> I mean, I can I can probably uh And then
what I can pro I could probably do
something around this like or write a
Python command or something.
>> Yeah. Or you could give it a code
execution tool that runs the Python for
you and goes and fetches the thing and
does it. Yeah. Cool.
>> Yeah. Or or I can or I can just modify
my Here's another thing I can do. Agent
tools.
>> I think context 7 has in some of their
fetch tools, they have a parameter that
is like max tokens. And so the model can
call the tool again and allow for more
tokens and it goes into whatever
summarizer model uh has that limit as
its max tokens and like its expected
amount of output.
>> Yep. There you go. Um, path.
>> Ah, cool. Okay.
>> I can just tell it this just like tell
me
>> and then you would just tell it, hey, it
was written to this path and the model
can use the read tool to go get it. I
love that. Actually, that's how that's
the right way to solve this.
>> Exactly. So, like
>> we do this with our linear tool as well.
Sometimes our linear tool, our CLI
brings back way too much markdown
content and so it's like cool, it will
just automatically save it to a file,
the CLI will, and just output, hey, it
was too long, so we put it in this file
and then the model can go read it.
>> Exactly. Um,
uh call the web fetch tool again with
the rest of the content. That's actually
a really good like takeaway in general
for building these agents and designing
these tools is like if you know the code
it's a coding agent and it has a read
tool and a search tool then you should
almost always rather than truncating the
output for the model you should just
write it to a file tell the model where
it is and then let the model decide
which parts of it it wants to read
>> and this is the whole point of like what
an aentic rag system can do it's very
dynamic so in this case I know some web
pages are going to be really long so
I'll just tell that but I'll
specifically put a cloth if you need
more information call the web fit
go again to get the rest of the contents
with a file path and it will probably
figure itself out. Like I I don't have
to think about this too hard. Um, and I
trust that this will work.
Uh, and then like it'll go ahead and do
its thing and then marin content will go
into here. And specifically what I would
actually do is over here. This error
message should actually not go there.
Uh, what I should do truncation. I have
a feeling this one's going to go more
than an hour, which I'm super down for.
>> Message this. And I apologize for the
live coding. Boom. And now I add this
added trim.
>> Oh, your your audio your audio bell is
is fascinating. I do not have that
turned on.
>> I I use it now because of like cursor
and stuff all the time. Um, so now we
have this we have a truncation message.
Uh, to-do rewrite tools. I didn't modify
at all. They just kind of worked along
the way. Uh, web search. I just used
Excel. I didn't even try. Um, it was
actually really easy to just use Excel.
It was great.
>> They just have a Python SDK. You don't
have to use the MCP or anything. You
just you just launch
>> Python SDK. Don't even think about it.
It's not worth it.
>> And it worked. It was beautifully
worked. And I didn't have to think about
it. Boom. Got the results. Joined it.
Put it in.
>> Uh, again did some more truncation. Uh,
and I can say the same thing again. And
I can again I should do I should
probably do the same thing right over
here too. Uh, and I should really just
make this 5,000. Sick.
Coming up on time, we got another
question.
What do you think about mapping the GP
results to metadata turn one, it shows
file names along with count per year and
tool response and then you search Q?
>> Yeah, I mean you can do a variety of
things to make this better. But I think
the key part that I really want everyone
to take away is what was the difference
here? The bulk of the time that I spent
wasn't actually on tool definitions at
all. almost all uh almost all the time I
spent was actually looking at how the
tools were implemented and like making
sure that it was really really friendly
for an agent. I spent a lot of time I
spent the first I probably spent about
an hour getting the whole thing up and
running. Then I spent another hour
purely getting um uh then I spent
another hour purely doing um basically
UI work to make the UI really good to
iterate on and then once I did that then
I actually add made the tools better. So
that and the reason was because I tried
to make the tools better without making
the UI better and I just couldn't I just
couldn't process the information well
enough about what was going on in the
agent loop to decide like where the
failure cases were.
And once I understood where all the
cases were, then and once I could
actually see and feel the agent, then I
could be like, "Oh, cool. Yes, the LS
tool needs to have dirt and file."
>> Oh, yes. Obviously, the GP tool should
be relative or the the uh the glob tool
should or GP one of those tools should
give the relative directory, not the
full directory. Oh, yes. Obviously, I
need to change my working path and the
system message and make sure the model
knows what directory it's in.
>> You want to see something cool? Um yes,
always.
>> Okay, so um one thing that we found in
digging in uh is like if you're going to
build these agents, it's actually
interesting to see how the coding
harness. So you won't see this if you
run cloud code. Um but in code layer, we
like to actually show you the exact
responses from the agent, not just the
contents of the file.
>> And one thing you'll notice is like I
assumed you didn't do this where you
actually put the line numbers in
>> to the file
>> if Well, I didn't do an I I should
>> Well, it depends on the model, right? So
you this is cloud code and this is like
the benefit you get when you're building
the model and the coding agent harness
is you can RL the model because the
model's going to have to make edits to
this right and so what's useful here is
like you can see when it does this old
string new string it can pick the line
numbers and it can see when it's
navigating or reading or pulling through
the file there's something been done
where these numbers are kind of rled in
such a way that it doesn't have meaning
as a number
>> I think you can do it with any model I
bet if I did this in my For instance,
some GPT models would work. Gemini
models would work on this.
>> I'm sure I'm sure it would work, but I'm
sure if you wanted to like push it push
push the limits of like exactly exactly
what outputs you would want from this.
Um, the training the training would help
to basically like deemphasize the
meaning of these things to ensure that
the weights imply when it's in this
format in this kind of file that it's
line numbers and not any other meaning
of that number. Maybe um maybe um but
like
>> we can only theorize at this point
because it's a closed model but
>> yeah my my hunch says that like most of
these systems probably work just fine
with any model. I think if you take a
model of like equivalent capacity the
key thing that makes a model really good
is how well it understands semantics and
that semantic of like hey this is a line
number not content should be pretty
obvious with the pattern of it
>> even without like any extra training. I
suspect training will get you a little
bit of a boost on top of it, but like as
the models get better and better and
they have more training data, that
probably matters less and less would be
my hunch.
>> Interesting. Yeah, I haven't looked
under the hood at things like Codex and
AMP and see if they use the same format.
But that would be that would be a sim if
you looked at Cotus and how it does file
reads and it didn't have those line
numbers, then that would be a signal to
me that they are being trained
differently as far as like how they
interact with the coding harness itself.
May maybe probably where my my hunch
comes from is that the cursor agent is
pretty good. I don't think it's it's
that much worse than like cloud code or
anything else like all these agents are
roughly the same from my perspective. Um
>> interesting
>> cuz I've been toggling now between like
cursor I've been toggling between codeex
and I've been toggling between um cloud
and I personally don't see a huge uptake
on any one specific agent. I actually
find that the thing that makes the
biggest difference to my efficiency is
actually the UX of how I interface with
these agents, not the actual like
uh context. And I find that like the way
that they implement the tools probably
makes a bigger difference. But because
all the tool calls are basically going
to be sending web API requests anyway,
all of these basically converge on very
similar tool calls because as soon as
one strategy gets discovered as soon as
enthropic discovers that hey we should
do GP in this way, I can promise you
cursor is like we should do GP in this
way and as soon as cursor discovers that
Enthropic is like we should do GP. It
just basically just cycles forever and
this stuff
>> because cursor is using the same models,
right? So they kind of have to take the
lead from anthropic to like figure out
okay here's what
>> I use the Gemini models I use code clog
GBT5 models but what I'm saying is I
think like if I were if I were Codex I
would just watch and I would just have a
harness test that says hey let's just
have a unit test that says anytime the
tool changes in I would just write a
bunch of unit tests that say trigger
these specific tools with these unit
tests observe what is happening
>> for all these tests and anytime the
format changes notify a user on the team
to be like we should look at this the
other agents have changed the format in
some way
>> because it might make a difference.
>> I'll show you another one is if you come
in here and you you we're using the
cloud code harness uh for everything in
code layer. Um and I will zoom in. Thank
you for thank you for the nudge. Um but
um if you go here and you change the
model to a different like if we go use
like um oh I'm going to stop sharing so
I can set my API key real quick. Sorry.
>> Um talking for a second. I I think some
of the models are definitely worse, but
I would try using like OpenAI GBT 5.
>> Uh so that one I don't have right now.
Um but if we go to open router and we
put in our open router API key, I'm just
going to show you what happens if you
use the like a non-cloud code model with
a uh with a with a cloud code harness.
>> Interesting.
>> Go. Let's grab this.
While decks are setting that up, what I
would advise everyone is I actually
wouldn't the reason that I actually am
really bearish on everyone implementing
aic rag and the these live agent systems
is because most people don't have
systems that need to be that broad. Like
while it is kind of nice, your users are
going to be a lot more confused when it
doesn't work. And I only spent 3 hours
making these tools better, but before I
shipped this, I would have to spend a
lot more hours actually trying a bunch
of scenarios on every single type of
system that I built. And there's a lot
of other stuff that is really hard to do
with these systems. For example,
streaming just takes a lot more effort
and engineering time to get right. If
you want to go do like for example
uh while I go what model are you using?
>> This is GPTOSS120B.
>> Okay. Yeah.
>> Much smaller model than Clad or Claude
Sonnet or Clad Opus, but we'll see. It's
also going to be a little bit faster
which is cool.
>> Yeah. So like before you go do any of
this stuff and decide to build a aentic
rag system I personally have found it
very useful to go ahead and build a
regular system without agentic rag and
once you've implemented that then you
can go ahead and then build uh a gentic
rag on top of that because then you have
some sort of expectation and baseline
that you're comparing against and it's
very similar to like a reference
implementation in any sort of software
where you always say like do the
reference implementation every single
time and that I personally find helps
you iterate much faster. It's kind of
similar to an eval loop, but instead of
regular eval, you're just doing AB
comparisons, which is actually what I
think is the more useful thing in these
sort of outcomes.
>> Okay, this GPT OSS appears to be
working. Um,
>> so yeah, you can you can do this for
simple stuff probably.
>> I Yeah, I think it's actually more about
model capability more than specifically
anything. I that's why I said like you
can you can probably swap in any model.
I was actually trying I I did GT5. I did
try the quad models. I tried Sonnet. I
did give it GPD40 nano uh GPD5 nano that
did not work very well
and like it just does it just doesn't
have the capacity I think that like GP5
has uh on the nano models.
>> Yep.
>> Like
>> uh Okay,
>> go ahead.
>> Sorry. Yeah, go ahead. I I was just
Let's just do like two more questions
and then we can call it for the day.
>> Um we've got a couple more questions
here. Let's just identify like where
does RL help here?
>> Um I think the point that Dextro is
making
Econ uh is that if you if you as a model
provider are also building a coding
agent, you can collect special data that
is specifically tied to your tool
implementations and you can actually
post-train the model to favor your
tooling format. So like fundamentally
anytime you're doing fine-tuning or
prompt engineering or context
engineering of any kind, all you're
doing is you're trying to tweak the
weights of the model to do what you want
it to do. with with fine-tuning and
reinforcement learning, you're doing it
at the weight layer. With prompt
engineer and context engineering, you're
doing it by modifying the input tokens.
>> Mhm.
>> So technically, there's a way to go in
RL here without having to change the
prompt again. Say for the static prompt,
make the result better.
>> Yeah. And so like I think if you
probably if you took an open model and
you trained it on this like harness that
you have built your your tools, your web
search, your file reading, all this kind
of stuff and you gave it a bunch of
coding problems, you could probably get
it better at using your specific tools
and in the exact way that they give
their outputs.
>> I mean, let's just do it really fast.
Why not?
>> Mik wants us to do a nano chat episode.
>> The GVD5 Mini is the model name, right?
>> Uh, sure.
I I don't know. Probably.
>> And if this thing runs and I know it's
working. Okay, that seems to work. Cool.
So, we can just see what this does. It's
going to run the same Fern tool as
before. What does a Fern folder do? It
read my to-dos. It was like, okay, cool.
No to-dos. It's going to glob the Fern
folder. And it seems to have produced
something
right over there. Uh, so it did produce
this and is able to understand this. How
do I use Gemini
with BAML? And I think this is again the
thing that Dash always say just like try
it and build your own intuition for
whether or not this works.
>> Um,
>> all right. We're going to make you learn
nano chat for the next episode. It's
been decided.
>> The first thing that I noticed that's
different, by the way, is check out this
GP. See how I did Gemini over here for
the GP tool?
>> When I did my old system, it actually
didn't when I actually did my old GP,
you'll notice the model actually made a
much better grip. It actually came up
with way more turn. So, that's one big
difference that we see right away in the
tiny model versus the small model.
Um, and also it didn't automatically
give me their example. It actually just
dumped out simply an understanding of
what it is, but it didn't actually give
me the example because it didn't
actually trigger the read tool probably.
So that was like another learning I had
when I was going to go do this was just
a really quick understanding of what is
actually happening under the hood. That
said, if we go look at how much this
thing costs, I suspect
>> cheaper.
>> Um, we are going to get very different
cost functions over here.
>> That's still right. we are getting much
much smaller costs and why is this split
uh this is split because the model
changed so the so the data database
actually split on itself automatically
uh because if the type signature of the
model changes then you get two different
data points
uh so when I did the grab like it's just
a lot cheaper and I think I find that to
be interesting to go look at and think
about
>> cool
>> so as always uh try stuff look at what
happened understand it feel the vibes
look at the data understand the accuracy
and the timing and the cost and all of
this and uh you know there's no right
answer. Agentic rag versus deterministic
rag versus a mix of the two versus
reranker pipelines inside your tools.
The answer is like what solves your
user's problem.
>> Do you want to see one last thing while
I'm here? Uh one really interesting
thing that I actually did when I was
running this code.
>> You might enjoy it.
>> Yen says you promised you'd get back to
this eval tool that you showed us.
>> Sorry. Um I'll talk about the code a
little bit more. Bob's building a really
cool evolve tool over at BAML and he's
embarrassed to talk about it cuz it's
it's really dope.
>> It's not ready yet. But um the whole
point of this is when I did the Asian
loop, there's a couple of different
things that happen. Sometimes the model
didn't respond to tools. Um but if you
notice my actual prompt that I actually
sent to the model,
uh let me render this again so you can
actually go read the full prompt. Like
the actual prompt that I sent to the
model, the way that I render tools, I
did a bit of context engineering. I
don't actually render tools the right
way. I actually render them this way.
It's like to-do read, here's no to-dos.
Then I actually render the tool again. I
say clob and then here's the actual tool
response. So I actually render the tools
in a very trivial way rather than with
pure JSON because again it's like I
don't want to render JSON and stuff in
the tool pattern. I want to dump it in
as a part of the context message. But
every now and then the model would
actually reply with like a similar kind
of reply where it just would say like oh
here's the here's a tool that I want. In
that scenario, I would actually want the
model to know even if it replied in that
way, I want to be very explicit and tell
the model it's like invalid response,
you must respond with one of the types.
So the model knows that hey, this is
invalid and I actually hide this from
the user. So the user will never see
this. Similarly, sometimes the model
will not reply with the reply to user
tool. It won't actually reply with this
structure. In that scenario, I actually
do a couple trivial checks. I'm like,
hey, if the model responds with a J with
back to JSON and doesn't start a curly
brace or um or this, then the model
probably was trying to reply to the
user. It just messed up. So rather than
doing a retry, I just take that
assumption. What does that look like in
practice? Is like some of these parsing
failures that you see over here.
I'll show it. Yeah, like this one. This
is a parsing failure because the model
actually responded like this. It said it
just responded plain text. And that's
okay because the model responded plain
text. What I do is I just say, "Oh, if
you're running in plain text and you're
not starting with a curly or this or
like tool something, then it's probably
right." So just send take it as a reply
to the user and just assume that the
model meant the reply here.
>> The model was just like too small and
dumb to follow the explicit instructions
of like here's the entire
>> context window got really big. So like
sometimes you'll see like a cursor gives
this error message. I saw this yesterday
where it's like the tool format wasn't
correct. It's like you can just patch
this really trivially. This is what I
mean by implementing your tools can make
a huge difference in some ways. getting
what tool to use is another tool of its
sort. So the way I implemented it was a
little bit smarter basically where it's
like if the model was trying to go do
something and it didn't exactly obey it,
I would just like recognize that it's
trying to do that and just like let it
keep going with that assumption. The
other thing I did was I said in the case
of it actually run turning an inval if
again if it parse if it was a parsing
failure rather than taking the exception
and dumping it in directly I actually
again made a slightly prettier error
message that says return an invalid
response dump the response I said must
be one of the types specified and with
that the model was able to go and fix
almost every bug and I never had any
more issues with the model not obeying
tool calls and I I put max retries three
I only ever really took one and what's
really important here is that this these
temporary states are actually temporary
states. They never go into the pure
state array of the of the final agent.
>> Uh so you put the feedback in, you let
the model correct itself, but then that
doesn't stay in the context window.
>> Exactly. And this was also really
important to making this work.
>> Yeah. And that's the other trade-off,
right? The manis folks are big on like
leave the errors in so it doesn't make
the same mistake again. But I think I
think you you were vibing with it and
you found what worked and and and this
was the thing that you wanted to do to
get the right results. Exactly. And the
model just doesn't make this message
make this type of error very often. So
because it doesn't make this kind of
error very often, it's not worth
breaking, if that makes sense.
>> And you and you've proven that this
reliably fixes it. So like it's not
really actually that expensive to drop
this in and then rip it back out because
>> I sent it to the full agent loop as a
whole just in case it made a different
error message. But I could have sent it
to a more trivial function that only job
is to fix it.
I just didn't want to risk it, so I just
send it to the full agent loop.
>> A look under the hood at how to best
build AI AI pipelines and AI agents.
This has been a really fun episode.
>> Yeah, this whole thing is going to be
live. Uh you will be able to just run UV
install and UV run sync and just run it.
Um it was a ton of fun to build and
while this was really really fun, I
would highly highly highly recommend
that every single one of you like
actually go build something like this.
you will learn so much by writing the
code and I like I always had an
intuition that aentic rag was uh pretty
cool. Uh but I didn't think I realized
how
how interesting it is for different
product surface areas for certain kinds
of things that I could never build
without it. So our Bammy chat agent what
I actually plan on doing is actually
plan on giving it a way to go abort out
of its main rag pipeline so it can go
into an agentic loop. The problem I have
with agentic loop is that it's just
super freaking slow. I just don't want a
system to be that slow. And for that
reason alone, I'm going to keep the
deterministic rag pipeline because it's
way faster. But every now and then,
someone will ask it a question like,
"Hey, how does this work?" And I want a
way to go trigger it into an agentic rag
pipeline. And the answer to that might
be there might be a button in the UI
that we build at the very bottom that
says something like uh let me clean my
window again. There might be something
here in here that says oh does this look
wrong to you? And I might put a button
here that says does this look wrong? And
if you press it it will actually trigger
the aentic rag system instead of the
main rag system. And that's a way for me
to opt into this without doing it all
the time and design it in a really nice
way. This is the same thing as you're
like, "Hey, look, we have a really tight
specific model that does 20 kinds of
classification." And then if the model
selects other or the user says it's
wrong, then you go to the big slow
expensive LLM to try to solve it.
>> Imagine imagine you're on this doc site
and you ask how to do this and it takes
you like you saw how long the other
system took. It's better, but it's
slower.
I just don't want that for here. And
like coding is different because in a
coding, why does why do coding agents
tolerate this kind of UX? Well, it's
because like the cost of me typing the
code is always long. It's always long.
So, it doesn't matter how long it takes
because it's always going to be faster
than me writing the code.
>> Hey, Ken, you want to do something fun?
>> Do you want to paste the research
codebase prompt into your coding agent
and see what happens?
>> My cloud code agent?
>> Your no your CLI agent that you wrote.
Take the take the research codebase
prompt that we use for uh working with
Claude.
>> That's actually really fun. And just see
if it works
>> here. I'll put it in the chat here.
>> Um, before I do that, I will take two
seconds and show you guys how this thing
works if you guys are curious.
>> Um, I think one of the key premises that
we had when we started this thing was
just I think it's important that people
should be able to see their code really
easily. So like one of the things that
we started with is just we just like
types. So we just store all your type
systems into the codebase and then you
can see your state messages and this is
a rendering bug because you can actually
turn this system into a quick little
test case that you can run locally
really really really fast. So, like if I
for whatever reason that agent wasn't
working, boom, I can just put this test
case over here. And now I think there's
some bug.
>> Now you have an eval of like, hey,
here's a long context. Can we get it to
still spit out the right answer even
with this long context?
>> Exactly. And then I can just build this
eval out really easily. And there's some
small stuff that I have to do uh in this
syntax like get rid of these commas.
But we're working on this and making
this better. So as soon as this is live,
we'll share it out. But one of the key
parts that we really wanted was just a
really easy way to understand how type
system work. Uh you want to be able to
see like the raw web requests that the
model actually made and make it super
easy for you to go see. So if it did
like reasoning of any kind, you should
just be able to see that trivially.
>> Cool.
>> You should be able to see network
requests, see timings, and everything
else on here. So like this took 60. That
looks wrong.
>> It's cuz you busted the cache, dude. Or
there's a bug.
>> No, that that's a bug. This is why this
isn't ready yet. We're just doing like a
quick few things on the type system. And
like one of the coolest things that we
really worked on was if you change the
type signature of any kind or you change
like the model or something else, the
data gets split out automatically for
you. So in this in this scenario that we
changed the model. So you notice that
there's two agent loops. One for model
A, one for the GD5 mini models and the
other one for the GD5 model that we had
here. And this kind of happens without
you having to think about it. So your
data is extremely clean is the premise.
And obviously stuff
>> had a really good summary of this. Let's
do the thing.
>> You want to paste it in. All right. I
put it in the in the chat if you want to
grab it.
>> Where? In the chat. In Riverside.
>> You scroll up like four messages in
Riverside.
>> I see it. I'm going to take this.
>> Paste it in. See what happens. I don't
think you you don't have a right file
tool, so it might not actually uh
>> it might not actually write the file,
but it will probably print it out to
you.
>> So, I've copied the codebase. Sorry, I
had to not screen share just in case I
showed something that I shouldn't.
Um, so let's go run this over here. What
we're going to do is we're going to do
two ti uh when we do this.
>> No, I mean just paste it into the CLI.
Oh, you're going to give it the edit
tool.
>> Of course.
>> Uh so you want the right tool then cuz
it's going to write a Oh, yeah. There
you go. Okay.
>> I'll give it all the scary tools. Screw
it.
>> Ship it.
>> Yeah, I guess
>> you already gave it bash.
>> Yeah, basically.
>> You're going to have to like cat that
thing.
>> No, no, no, no. I I have I have You
don't have to do that. It just starts.
Can I not? Okay. Well, that's not going
to work.
Um, I did not build command V into here.
Uh, let me run this again.
>> Oh, you can't paste.
>> No, I did not build command V into
there.
>> All right,
there might be quotes in here. So, you
will have to use I think try single
quotes around it instead.
>> Okay, let me try. Sorry, guys. This is a
live demo.
>> I'm putting Vib on the spot.
>> Okay, I'm
>> think there's any single quotes.
>> Okay,
>> unless there's like punctuation. What
does the fern folder do there?
>> Didn't like that. All right, we'll try
this later. We can put up a clip of it.
All right, we'll try one more. I think
there's punctuation. You got to do like
cat out of eof or whatever.
>> Here. You know what you got to do is uh
it's dash I
>> dash I What do you want me to do? I
>> I'm going to put it in I'm going to put
in the chat here. make this
>> welcome to the uh
>> into uh terminal within single quote.
>> You just got to give it the path to
that.
>> I'll just see what this does. This might
work.
>> Okay.
>> Um
>> No, you're just going to remove all the
single quotes.
>> I don't know. Um probably.
>> Oh, yeah. You could put in a file and
then just make it read the file. Nope.
Wrong.
>> No. What did it do? No.
>> Just save the file and then give it the
path to the file.
>> I haven't built that.
Oh, it can't read a file.
>> Yeah, it's Oh, maybe it can. Um Oh,
maybe. Oh, I didn't think about that.
That's a good idea. Uh I'm dumb. MD.
Okay, cool. Let's run this. Uh I think
this will work.
>> Yeah. Okay. So, just tell to read
research.m MD.
>> Okay. Read research.m
MD. Then uh then figure then use that to
learn what the fern directory does.
>> I have no idea what's going to happen.
>> See what's up. This is like a full like
curses toy. So when you resize the
window, it doesn't rerender.
>> It does eventually. Okay. So it did read
research MD. Did it not find it? I I
spelled it wrong. Okay. It's going to ls
and then it'll run again. Oh shoot.
Sorry.
Uh, my interruption was not built
perfectly. It was correct.
Read research.m
MD then uh, learn what the fern.
Yeah, it only rerenders every few loops.
This is what I meant. The hardest part
about building this whole system is
actually not the agent loop. It's
actually all the tooling around it. So,
like making this UI really good actually
took way more than I found. And like you
saw that it's kind of cool. Like I made
a to-do. Um, and like it's just going to
go build this out. But like having the
UI in influence was actually really
really hard. So we'll just see if the
cloud code prompt works.
>> Is this rich or typer or what is you
what is your UI framework?
>> I have no idea. This is cursor picked
one.
>> Updated the to-dos.
>> Yep. And eventually it'll rerender. I
think uh maybe that's a bug in the to-do
implementation.
>> This is also going to prompt it to use
sub aents. We'll see if it actually
launches sub agents. I don't know how
your sub aent UI looks. It just it will
trigger a sub agent. It'll show you. It
should be very obvious if it's
triggering a sub agent. Did you call it?
It should call a sub agent. If it
didn't, I mean, we can see if it did or
not.
>> You had a reply. It just said it read
that file path. Are you still using GPT5
Mini?
>> Yeah, I am.
>> Yeah. So, that's just not going to work.
There's too many instructions. Yeah.
See, it returned with tool colon.
>> Yeah. Yeah, exactly. Oh, that's because
my freaking loop was not good. Uh, I had
another bug over here. Uh,
>> yeah. This it looks like this block
didn't get hit.
>> There you go. This one, too. I need
both.
>> All right.
>> As you guys can see, this is a very,
very, very, very live demo. I did a
couple things. I swapped the model and I
returned and I also added that edge case
over here.
>> There's no way you're going to get GBT 5
mini to be able to to to do research
like that. Did you switch it back to
main?
>> I did.
>> Okay, cool. All right. And then in four
minutes, we're going to call this
episode for real because I know we both
have we both have companies to build.
>> So, it did build the to-dos. That's kind
of cool. I think I just don't have a
good UI for to-dos. There's some syncing
issue that I have in my UI.
>> Did you know that Claude removed the
to-do read tool because they they had
found that like the model was trained
well enough to just reinforce itself
with to-do write and it doesn't have to
be able to read its own to-dos.
>> Interesting.
>> Um
>> that might be it. So another thing to
notice is that one of the things that
cloud code does is you'll notice that it
sends you error messages and how it
keeps state. So like if you try and
write to a file that you have not read
yet, it forces it to read the file first
>> before it does that. That's another kind
of thing that you can do over here.
Cloud code also keeps track of what
files have been modified.
>> It like hashes it every time you read
it. And if you try to write it since the
last time you wrote it or read it, then
you don't get to
>> exly and it basically will say, "Oh, the
file has changed since you last read it.
Read the file again." And it actually
does a lot of work in that world to make
that easier.
>> It's same with context engineering
around how you keep like file iteration.
So like for example, one of our past
episodes were about dynamic memory and
like I think the person in that episode
or perhaps the episode after that was
talking about how like if you read the
same file five times, you probably don't
need to keep all five versions of the
file in the in the actual history of
what you're showing off. You probably
can show a different variation of it. So
like there's ways to manipulate the
context window historically and show a
different thing based on what your
current state representation is. And I
think having that idea is personally
like very useful.
>> Yeah. I mean, I think a lot of people
have been talking about like, hey, look,
like small context gets better results.
And people would rather just like be
constantly mutating the context window
to make it smaller and more compact than
lean on like even if it breaks the
cache, it just like I'd rather have that
cloud code do that thing where it's like
it will file reads from 10 turns ago
basically get condensed down into like,
hey, you read this file and here's what
happened versus like the fullon like
every single file we've read being
sitting in the context window.
>> That's cool. So, it made the to-dos and
now it finished reading that one and now
it's locating the fern folder. Um, and
then it should
>> 17 already.
>> This is the problem with the aentic rag
systems is like while they might work in
the end, they are really really
unbounded and how many times they work
and like I have no idea why it's calling
to-do right and to-do right over and
over again. Um, I'd have to like debug
that slightly better. So, like if I go
look into this like why is it doing
this?
>> You should just get rid of the to-do
tool. I think to-do lists are silly. You
should just not have along you should
you should not give a model enough tasks
that it needs a to-do list. You should
just use fresh context all the time.
>> Why is it? Oh, it's because it's doing
like globs and stuff like along the way.
And then it did a spam of to-dos.
>> Oh, it's just not showing those in the
>> Yeah, it's just not showing them in the
UI. And this is again why I like this.
It's like I can actually go see what
it's doing. Like why is it globing? It's
like infern. Okay, cool. That makes
sense. And like why is it writing to-do,
right? It's probably because there's
some bug in my to-do rendering. like
whatever bug is causing this to not
render here. It's probably the same bug
that is causing the model to go do this
and like and like not
>> it is slowly making progress though.
>> It is. And I think it will make progress
like it actually added a lot more docs
into like what the to-do is based on
this. And like why is doing a to-do read
every single time? I have no idea.
>> Yeah.
>> Um sick.
>> I have I should probably figure this out
and get this working a little bit more
fully. But if someone wants to go play
around with this and gets the to-do app
actually working, I think that'd be
super worth it for someone to go pursue
and think about. about how can you make
this system uh to do and figure out what
the bug is yours. I think it's like a
cursor bug to be honest.
>> Apache 2 license, go steal Vibbop's code
and turn it into a company.
>> Yeah, go do that. I don't care. Yeah,
this is a great do. If you make if you
if you make a business doing this, I'd
be so happy for you.
>> Amazing. All right, this was a super fun
episode. Uh biggest takeaway, I think
we've already said it, um but is
basically a rag, deterministic rag, it's
all balance. It's all solving problems
for your users. Make sure you actually
have a real use case to build against
and uh engineer the right amount of
things in the right places in the right
way.
>> Yeah. Uh just write a [__] ton of code
and you will probably get better at
building this kind of system.
>> Amazing.
>> Um
>> cool. Thank you.
>> Next episode, Tuesday, 10 a.m. Pacific.
We'll see you there.
>> All right. See you.
>> All right, fam. Take care. Tip.